[Music]
in london did you hear this this is a
cool story and london athletes at the
olympics are being issued 15 condoms
each
yeah so now every athlete's dream is to
return home with a gold medal and no
condoms
if you come home
[Music]
i got a gold medal and i still have my
15 condoms
speaking of olympic sex
that's my favorite transition in a while
it's pretty good
i meddled in that one
bronze uh
that's still pretty good
third in the world
not in the world uh
in my house speaking
[Laughter]
it's still pretty good in my house
usa
what the hell now you've changed your
flagger
you grew ashamed of your country that
quickly
speaking of olympic sex uh an olympic
sherpshooter check this out an olympic
sharpshooter from malaysia is going to
be eight months pregnant when she
competes in her event
isn't that crazy yeah the sharpshooter's
first target will be the bastard who
knocked her up
little bit of controversy from mitt
romney it's being reported that when
mitt romney spoke at the naacp last week
he may have brought as many as 200 of
his own african-american supporters
because nothing shows your commitment to
civil rights like saying i've shipped in
my own black people
[Applause]
[Music]
good i see you're all here we can begin
uh
also some controversy for the democrats
the democrats have apologized for using
mitt romney's horse in an ad
yeah still you got to love an ad that
ends with i'm mitt romney's horse and i
approve this message
that wasn't a horse that was a ghost i
just did no that was
that was horsey enough was horsey enough
it sounded more like a ghost to me oh
get you
the it's a goofy ghost the united states
postal service is about to default on a
5.5
billion dollar payment
yeah the post office claims they made
the payment but the check got lost in
the mail
[Applause]
[Music]
any burger king fans here
okay
they run ads on our show hey let's hear
it for burger king
yeah
i love all fast food monarchies
well a group of burger king employees
have been fired for taking a photo of
themselves with their feet in the
restaurant's lettuce
yeah yeah spokesman for burger king said
great there goes our secret recipe
still gotta love burger king though huh
[Applause]
this is interesting it's been reported
that modern family sofia vergara is now
the highest paid woman on television
highest paid women yeah
yet sadly she still can't afford shirts
that fit
it's really tragic
i see those breasts all the time
hey check this one out
that's code for i like this one
according to a professor at stanford
playing video games and watching porn
will lead to the demise of the male
species
yeah isn't that amazing i had no idea my
mother was a professor at stanford
that's insane
that's all she said
[Applause]